les chéris je voudrais qu'on fasse ça
vraiment un accueil trouve que c'est
vraiment beaucoup de coeur je le sais
c'est
vraiment le coup de coeur en ce moment
et c'est l'événement du moment on a la
chance qu'ils soient avec nous tous les
deux pascal plisson le réalisateur et
priscilla si tiéné qui est plus connu
ces gogos voilà le film gogo est sorti
aujourd'hui c'est le film à
l'exploit à l'école alors il y aura deux
traducteurs bien entendu alors qui est
gogo alors gogo merci d'être là je très
heureux de vous voir
maintenant on est très content tout le
monde est très heureux de vous avoir on
vous attendait vraiment depuis des jours
et des jours et pascal buisson je suis
fan de votre travail vous êtes un
extraordinaire vraiment vous êtes un
réalisateur mais vraiment qu'ils avaient
cessé axel vous nous fait rêver vous le
dis vous nous raconter toujours de
belles histoires vous nous fait rêver
c'est toujours intelligent c'est
toujours bien fait c'est toujours beau
ouais franchement je suis pas grave
j'ai rêvé d'avoir tous les deux ce soir
lotim sort aujourd'hui va voir la vidéo
la bande-annonce bien sûr nos bobos qui
l'a vu autour de la kaaba mercy west ham
à l'abri on voit que ouais
je m'appelle pressé la city neiges et 94
ans
cm2
ou bien font 4 x 3 60 concentre toi un
peu vos boucles sublime alors entendre
j'étais enfant je te fais travailler
dans les champs est surveillé vaches et
puis en ce temps-là l'école c'était pas
important combien font 10 x 10 ans ça
fait sens oui
je réussir mon examen
je trouve que dans cet uniforme j'ai
plus d'ailleurs que n'importe quelle
manie qui reste au village
t
merci la mersey
alors
pascal alors je connais l'histoire mais
comment vous êtes intéressé à gogo je
crois que si vous aviez vu un faux
faites vous la connaissiez pas du tout
vous avez bien je crois un reportage ou
non j'ai en fait c'est un ami qui est au
kenya qui me l'a qui vous a parlé de
wiki et 4 une petite annonce dans un
journal local comme quoi au kenya dans
sa région où il y avait la plus vieille
que l'ire du monde en primaire
évidemment j'y suis allé voir tout de
suite govou dans son village et je suis
tombé sur une femme exceptionnelle et on
à 94 ans il avait 94 ans quand je les
rencontre est donc là elle en a plein à
98 d'aujourd'hui
entre le moment où je le rencontre et le
tournage le film qui était décalé
plusieurs fois à cause des colis dès la
sortie de d'hier far away ou aujourd'hui
que je veux dire oui à la 98ème 10920
croit les manifs c'est vrai qu'elle a ma
gueule alors go tout d'abord a dû
redoubler s'avère doublé elle travaille
et malal blandin peut aller
à 94 ans a gardé un peu
c'est ça au début elle redouble absolue
est en fait l alcool sur le tournage
comme tonton là qu'on a tourné elle a
perdu la vue un petit peu et ça sans en
parler après mais alors doublé plusieurs
fois parce qu'elle a passé 6 ans ou
septembre faire ses classes primaires et
gogo à vous recevez le soutien de tous
les enfants et sa petite fille mexès est
magnifique
gogo c'est la première fois que vous
venez en france ça prouve à vous quitter
même le
oui et oui c'est la première fois
qu'elle vient en france et c'est la
première fois même qu'ils sont plus qu
elle quitte son village exactement c'est
ça et c'est ça vous a envie de retourner
dans votre village où vous êtes bien ici
voulait rester avec nous
[Rires]
donc également des chroniqueurs alors on
va voir la vidéo regardez c'est très
touchant quand bogoro d'où le regard
mousse non non non non
c'est
pas tout
ça qu'il
ya
[Musique]
habibi kosova lui à touques et habitat
hockey
alors elle revoit les bassins
comme le bruit des éléphants et c est
évident
alors il ya un moment où on en a parlé
c'est gogo a eu des problèmes aux yeux
elle n'arrive pas avoir correctement et
là encore elle a été soutenue
accompagnée pour aller voir un docteur
et la soigner ça ça a changé sa vie
beaux gosses assez c'est fou parce que
on voit votre visage quand vous revoyez
est vraiment on est on dirait qu'on est
dans votre tête qu'on est dans vos yeux
one
c'est fabrice di vizio qui fait
comme ça et l'avait mal aux yeux
l'aed vous êtes heureuse maintenant
beaucoup plus à alès maintenant elle est
content c'est un moment c'est un moment
fabuleux doublé cela parce que nous
c'est un documentaire donc on filme la
vie des gens sans intervenir et s'est
avéré que pendant le tournage à la
moitié de tournage elle a commencé à
perdre la vue alors elle voit pas d'un
bon oeil mais elle a une cataracte
qu'elle avait une cataracte très
prononcé et en fait elle a loupé elle
n'a pas pu aller au bout de sa scolarité
à cause de ses yeux et à cet âge là une
opération c'est fou oui mais c'était
c'était ça où j'arrête les études et je
reste chez moi je ne vis plus ça lui a
changé la vie ok et depuis ce temps là
tous les tous les gens âgées du village
viennent si l'europe est là cataracs et
regardez regardez le moment où elle
explique ses problèmes oculaires waouh
ou un appel aux femmes nana tanko aqua
tube le nom one was wazekwa bois ou ta
cousine quoi vous voyez vos mimiques à
madère est originaire de croyants gbagbo
il utilisait retourner à kaboul une
patte amati papouasie ça veut dire des
membres actuels de caractère et vous
aurez tous deux étaient nasa macho et
new wave mona vous aurez os x n'a pas de
faille des nations can
hamada les toitures
[Musique]
c'est un beau et surtout le moment pour
moi le plus émouvant du film c'est
l'après opération
tout s'est très bien passé quand elle
revoit ça c'est un moment incroyable
quand vous avez filmé ça vous aussi vous
êtes dit j'ai un moment c'est fou ce
moment dit oui c'est dingue parce qu'en
fait moi je moi même je pensais même pas
qu'avec la cataracte ont été opéré le
jour même le lendemain 26 ans voyait
comme un vrai et donc à part un petit
peu mal à cause et médine à cause de
l'opération mais sa halle vacheresse
avait du jour au lendemain et du jour au
lendemain elle a retrouvé une vie
normale comme avant
regardez
[Musique]
alors
ça n'a pas été facile aussi de retourner
en classe pour vous gogo parce que vous
avez dû batailler pour convaincre le
directeur de l'école de vous acceptez
vous avez essuyé beaucoup de refus voilà
ils croyaient pas en votre volonté de
vouloir lire de vouloir écrire au début
à l'arrivée
comme fc voilà c'est la régie quoi c'est
[Rires]
rien c'est
bien
ce qui a deux traducteurs
[Rires]
fo lire vos amis
1 un gros boulot voilà
ce que je pense qu'il traduit en fait
qu'est ce que je fais
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
elle a commencé chercheurs et
colonie d'itamar a ajouté louis olive
oil a commencé par expliquer aux
primaires à voter jusqu'à elle a été
parfaite et
qui nous lient camerata
le directeur à
la répondu qu'est qu'elle pouvait la
prendre parce que il ya l'école
possédant toutes
rentrées chez elles
après l'arrivée
la conforte le dire et alors cette année
y est allé talent et à hodeidah ou
la cellule ou direct à
tous même semaine elle a retourné
la prochaine fois cette fois ci à le
dire et à la rejeter en piste c'est du
monde à leimbach hibou et l'a payée à
quelques semaines mollet
à bas niveau et c'est afrique et
l'uniforme
a été l art venu à l'écho la marque
elle a été bien accueillie par les fonds
mondial et les enfants étaient très
contents tout leur talent
depuis elle à l'école et l'a jamais été
alors il y avait des familles leurs
sigles
les bernard montiel
bernard montiel comme toutes les
avant-premières un rien entendu bravo
bernard voilà bernard montiel qui
étaient là voilà donc allemand david
avec la musique du film oui il y avait
surtout un buffet à mon avis
et lommois de trois petits fours c'est
sûr et certain il y avait dû y avait du
festi
à égal on a également une photo à le
regarder ça c'est une faute parce qu'il
ya des brigitte makoun est venu à
l'avant première du film et oui voilà
quitté le zénith est là elle a aimé le
film brigitte macron alors brise macron
avait très envie de voir ce film je n'en
avais parlé j'ai eu la chance de voir le
film il ya déjà un peu plus d'un mois
même deux mois je crois bon c'est un
film je les raconte est tellement
bouleversant tellement remplie d'amour
et puis de ce message ses messages
merveilleux qui a dans le film message
d'espoir n'y a pas d'âge pour apprendre
cette femme qui travaille très durement
dans son village qui consacre sa vie à
l'éducation pour inciter toutes les
jeunes filles du village
il faut savoir capter merveilleux
millions de femmes qui n'ont pas que sa
ligue du cash voilà enfin pascal bien
sûr heureux bien sûr pour ça qu'il
importe on suit mais les 13 pour la
démarche de google et elle est très
engagé qui a sensibilisé la première
dame évidemment puisque elle même est
très impliqué puisqu'elle a ouvert trois
écoles en france où elle même a presque
important pour elle d'y aller la très
important elle y tenait absolument elle
était ravie de venir et elle était ravie
de rencontrer gogo qu'elle a beaucoup
aimé et gogos qui est timide là sur le
plateau aujourd'hui je peux vous dire
gear l'était pas timide aucun cas la
danse est elle assez exactement elle a
dansé dans la salle hier soir et elle
est en pleine forme et on est très
heureux parce que vous savez pourquoi
les timides ce qu'elle voit que je n'ai
pas beaucoup et à l'école donc ça la
salle
[Rires]
pascal a alors regardé notre photo si
vous étiez avec les producteurs du film
pendant brassens était pana ce bagne
ramzi khiroun nos amis voilà et il ya
marie dauzier rossi qui est très
importante aussi bien sur ce que ce film
existe grâce à larry exactement mari
qu'on embrasse a été c'est grâce à elle
que je suis michael c'était un combat
pour me les cibles parce qu'en fait on a
découvert l'histoire en décembre de
18 il fallait qu'on tourne en mars 2020
parce que l'année commence et on a vu
que c'était là pour tourner donc il a
fallu accélérer la production s'était
pas été simple de convaincre les gens
tournent et aussi l'histoire avec une un
personnage de 94 ans ll rompt alors par
contre beaucoup elle repart dimanche
d'accord harcelé les repas a bien sûr
avec plaisir elle sera ravie je pense je
vous dépose à l'aéroport
libère
elle s'en fout
[Rires]
bobo merci audouy montlouis montbernard
non c'est juste quelque chose de très
important qu'il faut dire aussi c'est
que du coup monsieur blanc caire le
ministre des questions nationales va
également le proposer dans les écoles
tellement il est maire
avoue pascal je suis parce que c'est
qu'ils mirent en fait son message est
très important elle provoque des
questions des jeunes filles c'est ça les
problèmes au kenya et surtout
l'éducation des jeunes filles mères 13
ans pour des enfants qui se grattent
lance des exclus du clan familial exact
se retrouve seul dans la nature sans
mari et qui ont qui abandonnent l'école
donc son combat c'est de convaincre ces
jeunes filles mères de retourner à
l'école de continuer l'école malgré
qu'elles souhaitaient les enfants alors
qu aux açores aujourd'hui merci pascal
puis soudain c'est nouveau
[Applaudissements]